You have all these voices
that are telling you you're fucked up,
and this is going to be hard.
But for some reason, you put
so much practice into you
that you can ignore every one of 'em
that are telling you you're
not going to fucking make it
and still be able to fucking make it
because you have put the practice in
that you know this is the process.
It's such a daunting task that
all the voices are saying no,
but you still had the conviction that,
"I know I can do this,"
and that's what it took
for me to get here.
When you put that practice in,
every day you lace 'em up...
And I don't mean run. It's
just a metaphor for life.
When you lace them
motherfuckers up every day,
pretty soon you win.
You have the courage and
the heart and the dedication
and the mindset about everybody
can go fuck themselves.
I know what I know.
I've listened to myself enough
to know I know what I know.
None of you can hear what I'm hearing.
And that's what people don't do enough of.
They don't listen to their journey.
They listen to everybody else's shit.
You're not looking at the
truth in front of you.
The truth in front of you is it sucks.
This is what it takes,
creating another voice
and sometimes going at it alone.